cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la ville les
clayes sous bois
nous avons bien entendu les 10 ans de
noir et que vous savez déjà samedi
pour cela on organise aussi une
rétrospective des films joués par
philippe noiret comme alexandre le
bienheureux cinéma paradiso ou zazie
dans le métro qui seront jouées dans les
deux semaines à venir
nous avons aussi une grande sélection de
films comme par exemple le dernier film
d'animation de zabou breitman les
hirondelles de kaboul
nous avons également la vie scolaire
tant attendu la comédie dramatique
française et nous avons également deux
mois le dernier film de klapisch deux
protagonistes
rémy et mélanie un peu perdu dans notre
société actuelle où on est dans une
génération 2.0 elle qui cherche l'amour
sur les réseaux sociaux
lui qui perçoit science a rencontré une
jeune femme lors de chemins vont se
rencontrer
peut-être sera-t-il pour un amour commun
c'est à vous de le voir je vous invite
donc à aller voir chez nous mais c'est
quand même dingue de tomber sur
quelqu'un qui a vraiment vraiment mais
rien à dire y a pas parlé pendant une
heure six randonnées il m'a dit j'ai
l'impression que ça fait des années que
je te cherche l angoisse
tu te rappelles toi journée un farine
les carry trades est karine karine pdg
d'accor alors une prune à laver les
mains un débouclage non les intérêts
dans des soucis dans sa tête
et
[Musique]